this show has forever changed my life it
is the greatest experience i have ever
had
beyond my wildest imagination
call it ellen's final dance the comedian
signing off from her signature talk show
after 19 seasons on thursday
thank you so much for being on this
journey with me
i feel the love
and i send it back to you
bye
[Applause]
i love making people happy and i love
seeing people laugh and have a good time
and she did just that one last time
bringing the laughs with her final
monologue when we started the show i
couldn't say
gay on the show i was not allowed to say
gay
i said it at home a lot i you know what
are we having for our gay breakfast or
past the gay salt
has anyone seen the gay remote things
like that but the tears flowed soon
after ellen reflecting on the impact the
talker had on her life
because of this platform we have been
able to change people's lives and this
show has forever changed my life it is
the greatest experience i have ever had
beyond my wildest imagination
so twitch one last time
dance with me
the source tells e.t ellen's last show
was emotional for her it feels like an
end of an era but she is ready for the
next chapter of her life it feels
bittersweet you have to embrace all the
moments in life because they all add to
something that makes you a better person
ellen taped the episode last month going
out with a bang by taking things full
circle inviting her first ever guest
jennifer aniston
it's a welcome map it's a welcome map
back for the finale jen was quick to
sympathize with ellen explaining how she
handled saying goodbye to her own iconic
show friends back in 2004. you know well
i went i got a divorce and went into
therapy
and then um oh and then i did a movie
called the breakup i just kind of leaned
into the end
next up billy eilish you started this
show the year after i was born uh yes so
yeah
this you know this was in my house yeah
constantly all every day yeah and really
i would walk into the kitchen and my mom
would be watching and it wouldn't be an
ellen show without a performance so pink
who sang the show's most recent theme
song took the stage
[Music]
then ellen closed out the show with this
heartfelt message if i've done anything
in the past 19 years i hope i've
inspired you to be yourself your true
authentic self and if someone is brave
enough to tell you who they are
be brave enough to support them even if
you don't understand
they're showing you who they are and
that is the biggest gift anybody can
ever give you
and by opening your heart and your mind
you're going to be that much more
compassionate and compassion is what
makes the world a better place
so what's next for ellen well when her
wife portia appeared on the show earlier
this month she offered this idea i want
to make sure that you continue being a
teacher
because that's really what you've been
for everybody
and
you know i just i just feel like
more than ever we need
love and light and laughter
and uh so i hope that you continue to do
something like that uh like stand up
stand up or whatever i mean really but i
don't really have an opinion but yeah
stand up yeah would be good and twitch
who's been ellen's dj sidekick on the
show since 2014 knows this won't be the
last we see of her she's not going away
it's just this saga the of the ellen
degeneres talk show this one is coming
to a close but ellen degeneres is ellen
degeneres yeah absolutely
[Music]
you